[Music]
with mommy
should I say he has I'd ask let me stay
here it's design and yes I do speak a
little bit of German because I've lived
here for eight years when I was a kid so
it's always really nice to come back
here because there is a lot of memories
involved and it's been 23 years since
the last time it snowed on me so I'm
very much looking forward to tomorrow so
I'm a front-end developer and over the
last the last three years I've been
doing a lot of work with SVG because SVG
excites me
it is both an image format and an object
and the document format and there's so
much possible with it I'm not a designer
but I wish I were particularly I'm not
really well I do like web design but the
kind of design that excites me the most
is print design so as a kid I always
used to grab magazines and browse them I
still do that today with digital
magazines I rarely ever read the text in
them I just like looking at them I love
the layout
I love the imagery I love the effects
included in it so and I started with the
web I wished I could do on the web or
actually I expected to be able to
recreate certain print designs on the
web but it wasn't really that possible
before but the gap between what's
possible in print design and editors
such as Photoshop and what's possible on
the web has been getting a lot smaller
over the last few years in fact this
grab has always been very small it's
just taken us an awful lot of time and
years to realize it and to pay attention
to the parts of the web that do make
that gap small now when it comes to CSS
over the last three a few years mostly
three or four years it's been getting a
lot of features that make the scab
smaller it started with printed with CSS
shapes which which allow you to create
content that wraps around and inside
irregular shapes i got extreme can
imagine i got extremely excited when i
saw this back then i was even one of the
first people to write these articles on
them and then with the introduction of
CSS blend modes which also enable us to
do a lot of color compositing and
blending to create really nice effects
that are also part of what you always
see in poster design and print design
and then there is CSS filters that
enable that in
to do more image editing right in the
comfort of our code editors there are 11
filter effects possible that do a range
of effects from blurring to change in
color to contrast and saturation and all
of that and one particularly interesting
function is the URL function which
enable us to import even more complex
functions and new functions and to CSS
from SVG now extruded CSS has made this
gap smaller of the last few years but
SVG has always had a lot of features
that have been around for a very long
time in fact these CSS filters and most
of what's possible in CSS when it comes
to graphic design has been imported from
SVG the CSS versions here are optimized
fairly optimized versions of filters
that are currently available in SVG and
that are even more capable for example
it is currently possible to blur an
image using the CSS blur function okay
and the image above I'm blurring it
using six pixels so the blur is applied
uniformly over the entire image both in
the horizontal and the vertical
direction but this function is merely a
simplified and very limited shorthand
for the blur function that is available
in SVG so SVG allows you to blur an
image either uniformly just like you do
with CSS or if you provide two values
two numerical values you can speed them
blur the image on the x axis and the y
axis separately differently or at the
same time so you can imagine can use
this effect for example the be
horizontal during you can create a
motion blur effect if you combine it
with other filters as well now I know
that for me I did it too so at some
point I did wonder why would I want to
use these effects on the web why don't I
just create an image and you know just
embed it on the website right it's just
one image you create it and then you
embed it well the first problem is if
you're building responsive websites then
you're not just dealing with one image
if you think about it because you have
multiple resolutions we have picture and
sources and other resources that that
enable us to embed different image
resolutions for different screen sizes
and we have to do that and if you want
to change anything about your effect you
have to jump back into Photoshop or
whatever editor you used to create it
and then you have to edit it and then
you have to edit all of the versions of
that image and then you have to reinvent
them now in addition to that there are
other reasons now the ability to apply
filter effects on the web helps us
maintain the semantic structure of the
document instead of resorting to images
which aside from being fixed resolution
most of the times they tend to obscure
the original semantics of the elements
that they replace and this is
particularly important when it comes to
text if you want text that has a
specific filter or effect applied to it
and you create it as an image and then
you embed it you lose the semantics of
that text it's no longer searchable not
selectable it's not accessible anymore
and that is not right so the content
semantics are preserved this is the most
important point personally for me the
content is editable and dynamic so if
you want to change that text you can do
that in the comfort of your code editor
you don't have to jump into the graphics
editor change it and then we embed it
it's easier and faster to tweak the
change either the content or the effect
itself if you're applying it with code
you can change it again you don't have
to resort to the design design editor
anymore and the effects are animatable
so if you create an effect as an image
and then you embed that you can't
animate it even if you have multiple
versions of that image and then you're
animating between those images is not
really a transition anymore it's not it
doesn't look good for example with CSS
filters you can create an effect that is
as simple as this one here which it just
fades an image and an ounce and you can
change anything about it you can play
with the contrast with the colors and
you can do that using just a few lines
of CSS and using filters on the web can
also be a really nice addition for
progressive performance so you know
Kravitz has this really nice technique
it's called contrast swap where you
create an image in Photoshop and then
you reduce the colors in that image and
then you embed it on the website and
then you re increase the colors or you
edit the colors using CSS filters so the
image that you're embedding is a much
smaller size than the original image
which would contain all of the colors so
you have a smaller image you are
embedding a smaller image is better for
performance and then you get the
benefits or you reapply this effects on
the web using CSS now there's a lot of
controversy around that
issue like if you want to download the
image is going to be downloaded without
the filter effects and stuff like that
but it's still a really nice and a
really nice effect if you want to do it
now filter effects an SVG are defined
using the using filter elements a filter
element filter elements are never
rendered directly they're only usage is
as something that you can create and
then you reference and apply later on
certain elements it could be images it
could be text it could be anything such
elements elements that are only defined
and then reapplied a referenced are
usually raps and deaths deaths is short
for definitions and some element and SVG
whatever you put into a deafs element is
not going to be rendered on the page but
when it comes to filters whether you
wrap them in the Deaf's or not it's not
really it doesn't make any difference
because it's not gonna rendered the
reason it's not gonna render anyway
because the reason for that is that
filters require a source image to work
on and unless you explicitly dis define
that source by calling the add the
filter on that source image then it's
not gonna have anything to render and so
it's not going to render so you can put
it in the Deaf's element or not it's up
to you now a filter effect to create and
effect whatever that effect it's made up
of a series of operations and each
operation is created or as done or is
applied using a filter primitive in SVG
all of these primitives are prefixed F
with F e F E is short for filter effects
so you have F a blend which is the blend
filter effect and then you have Fe
composite compositing effect each filter
primitive performs a single fundamental
graphical operation on one or more
inputs one or more so an effect can be
applied to either one input or it can
take two inputs and apply the effect
using those two inputs this input can be
it's gonna get very technical from now
on okay the input can be the original
image the source graphic is called the
source graphic and SVG it could be the
results of another primitive so you can
chain filters together the result of one
primitive can be used as an input to
another primitive or it can also be the
alpha channel of an element which is
essentially a black version of that of
that element this in turn means like you
have you have more than 19 filters
Viji each one of they can all be changed
they can be chained they can be you can
take an input from one of them and use
it for more than one more than an input
for more than one other filter
primitives we have almost an endless
combination of filters and therefore an
endless combination of primitives the
sky is the limit
now before diving into the examples and
we're gonna talk about some of these
filter primitives and create some really
nice effects with them I want to cover
another topic really fast it's called
the filter region the the set of filter
operations need a region to be applied
on okay so suppose you're applying a
filter effect on one of many elements
and the SVG how do you tell the SVG that
you want that effect to be restricted to
a specific area and not be applied on
everything else on the on on the SVG or
maybe you want to do it the other way
around you have multiple images multiple
elements on the page and you want the
effect to be applied on the entire SVG
you can do that by specifying the filter
region or editing the photo region so
each element has a small region every
element and SVG has a small region whose
boundaries are defined by the borders of
the bounding box a bounding box also
called a short but the short version is
called be box in SVG it is the smallest
fitting rectangle around an element okay
so if we have text this is what the
smallest fitting rectangle could look
like it could also have some padding on
the top and bottom because the line
height also counts here the bounding box
of an element is by default the filter
region for an element so if you apply an
effect to this text for example it will
be restricted to that small rectangle of
the text however some filters affect
pixels that are that lie outside of that
bounding air but bounding box for
example if you apply a blur effect and
you look at this image here on the right
side and on the left side you can see
that the blur being clipped off and that
is very undesirable now according to the
specification it is often necessary to
provide padding space in the filter
region because the filter effect might
impact bits slightly outside the tight
fitting bounding box okay for these
purposes it's possible to provide you
can change the value we can change the
area of the region by changing the
position of
the top left corner and the width and
the height of that region and in order
to expand it you need to be able to
provide negative values for the X&Y
positions and that is actually possible
so if we were to visualize the filter
region area we'd be able to see that
this padding indeed exists by default so
it is the the filter region is the
bounding box but if you look at it if
you really visualize it in real life
it's not really just the bounding box it
is a little bit more than that now first
of all I want to talk about how I
visualized it so I'm using a filter here
and we have the FC the filter effect
it's got the flood filter effect what
the flood does is it literally floods
the filter region with color it just
floods it it the cut lip color is gonna
cover everything in the filter region
but when it does that is going to cover
everything behind it so the text will no
longer be visible so in order to put the
text back I'm going to be using these
filters and the rest of the examples as
well and that's why I'm covering them
right now so in order to report the text
on top of the image you can merge both
the flood color and the source graphic
using the merge filter function each
merge element has children elements what
each one of them is called merge mode
these are essentially just layers so the
first one takes and the flood color and
the second one takes in the source
graphic and it puts them on top of each
other the ones that come later are the
ones that on top so we have flood and
then source graphics the source graphic
is going to be on top each layer okay is
called an emergent but you need to keep
in mind that you need to keep something
in mind here the units that you use to
change the the origin and the size of
the filter region are can be in
percentages or they can also be in
pixels if you set them in percentages
they're going to be relative to the
bounding box of the element okay so if
you want to move to extent to expand it
you extended you would use minus 5%
minus 5% not positive here and then you
could extend it to a hundred and 20
percent in in width or if you use if you
use the user space on use as the
coordinate system which is essentially
the entire SVG then you can specify the
filter image
and pixels but when you do that is going
to be relative to the entire SVG these
are a little bit of small technical
details that I needed to cover and now
we can start creating some effects now
the most basic effect that you're
probably most of the times find and
tutorials about SVG filters is creating
a drop shadow because it's a very simple
one fairly straightforward and it gives
you a clear idea of how chaining works
and how then merging layers and stuff
like that so I'm gonna create this
effect here I just have an image I want
to create a drop shadow the drop shadow
is a very light drop shadow it's not
very dark so it's not really black we're
gonna have to change that color into
gray sure okay so you can start that by
creating a filter element inside of that
filter element you use the offset filter
primitive the offset primitive offsets
the input image relative to the to its
current position and the image space by
the specified vector so I specified DX
and dy and then the DX and dy will move
the image on the X and y axis
respectively this is this offset filter
is you is most important in effects like
these like creating drop shadows and
this is why we're using it here now and
then the second one is the Gaussian blur
Gaussian blur effect so the Gaussian
blur effect takes a standard deviation
which specifies the amount of blur that
you want to use you can specify one
number only which creates a uniform blur
or you can specify two numbers if you
want to create only horizontal or
vertical or different horizontal and
vertical effects the end that we're
using in the offset we're taking the
source alpha and then we're moving that
source alpha well if you have if you
have a JPEG image then the Alpha Channel
of that image is always going to be one
because it's fully opak and so the Alpha
source alpha the Alpha channel is going
to be a fully black rectangle which is
the same size as the image and this is
what we have here so we get the black
rectangle we offset it and then we blur
it using Gaussian blur next you you
flood if you want to color your plot you
want to apply a color to that shadow
right you don't want it to be completely
black anymore so you can use a flood a
flood we're flooding the area with a
very light gray color the hashtag BBB
and
which is going to give us the color
result and then you then you use the
composite function now compositing is
the combining of a graphic element with
its backdrop okay a backdrop is the
content behind the element and what is
the element is what the element is going
to be composited with using different
compositing operations there are sixteen
different ones you can specify which
parts of the source and the backdrop are
going to be visible so you would have
something like this if you have two
elements one of them is blue and one of
them Avia is yellow and they overlap in
certain areas different composite
operations are going to tell the browser
which parts of that you want them to be
visible so in our case here the flood
color is on top so it is the source and
the backdrop the the the shadow is the
backdrop which is the destination and we
only want to show the part which is the
backdrop itself which is the shadow so
we use source and in this case if we do
that
we're gonna end up with only showing the
parts where the flood color and the
shadow intersect which happens to be the
shadow and it's going to be the color
gray which is the flood color so
essentially we're literally coloring the
flood shadow
coloring the drop shadow with the flood
is confusing so at this point the only
thing that is visible on the page is
this year we have a rectangle we have it
blurred and we have it colored but we so
we have the drop shadow but we don't
have the image how do you combine them
using merge so you get the shadow you
put that in a merge node and then you
put the source graphic on top and you
end up with this very small effect so
upset the source alpha use that for
input for the Gaussian blur the Gaussian
blur is going to blur it and then you
flood the area with color and then you
composite that color with the shadow you
have a colored shadow and then you merge
that shadow that you created with the
source alpha and that's how we create a
simple drop shadow
another simple primitive that I
personally really like is the FE
morphology morphology to morph an
element means to transform the shape or
the form of that element the morphology
filter effect operates on the form of
the object at
- values the first one is erode and the
second one is dilate to erode an element
means to make it thinner to dilate means
to make it thicker and this is literally
what this primitive does it either makes
the element thinner of Earth makes it
thicker now the amount by which you make
it thinner or thicker is specified using
a radius attribute and even though we're
saying radius which usually refer means
a circle or an ellipse the browser
doesn't really use a circle in order to
make this erosion our dilation using the
number that you specify and radios the
browser is going to create a matrix or a
kernel which is then used to do this
this kind of erosion and dilation this
is a little bit technical jargon but
it's necessary to know so when you apply
to a graphical JPEG image to a
photograph erode and dilate have very
very predictable results so the image is
going to be transformed in a sort of a
an image that has been painted with a
real really large strokes of color and
this is literally what it what it looks
like and if you were to animate the
effect to see how it works it's the one
on the top right so you start with the
image and the thicker you make it or the
more the the stronger the morphology you
have let me repeat that
[Music]
the thicker or the wider the strokes get
under less detail you have in the image
the only thing that you might notice in
this slide is that when you apply these
effects you have a road and you have
dilate the difference between the image
on the top right and the one on the
bottom left is the color one of them
looks that it has lighter strokes and
the other one has darker strokes this is
because again a little bit of technical
stuff erode sets each pixel to its
darkest or most transparent neighbor
whereas dilate sets the channel to match
the brightest or least transparent one
so morphology when applied to images has
a very predictable effect that image did
get if you look really close the image
with when you apply erode it gets it
does get a little bit smaller on the
edges around the edges whereas dilate
makes it a little bit wider one was dark
one is like very predictable effect now
this is all too much again gibberish so
for single
objects such as text for example erode
makes the object thinner or dilate makes
a thicker we can take advantage of this
fact to fix something fix something that
we usually want to do an SVG but we get
unpredictable results for so if you want
to add a stroke to text an SVG you can
do that you think using the stroke
attribute okay so if you add a stroke
you can do that like this
stroke deep pink this is the color that
I used most of the times because it's
the easiest you add a deep pink stroke
and you give it a stroke width and you
end up with the results on the second
line here what happens when you add a
stroke or an outline you want to add an
outline but if you do it using stroke
you end up with the text that that's
that got thinner so that stroke actually
ate up part of the text and this is
probably not the effect you want if you
want to add an outline you want to
preserve the size of the text and then
add the outline to the text if you use
stroke this is the result that you get
you're going to eat up some of the text
but if you use SVG filters you can fix
that
so what do you have here we have we have
a source alpha we have text okay we take
the source alpha of that text and then
we operate it we specify the operator on
it on the morphology filter to be dilate
so we want to make the text thicker okay
by three pixels and then we flood the
area with color let's sleep tank again
which results in a pink flood area and
then we composite remember compositing
you specify which parts is going to
elect you're gonna clip off something so
in this case here if you use the
operator M what's gonna happen is you
have a color on top and then you have
the the text and the background and when
you composite them together that the
dilated text and the color you're gonna
end up coloring the text and then and
then you merge you merge the recolor
text with the source graphic so you have
the original text which is in black and
then you have a pink version a dot a
pink dilated version of that text okay
you have them on top of each other and
then you show them on top of each other
with merge so you end up with the one on
the bottom here so literally right now
you
two layers of text the one in the behind
is the text itself but it has been
dilated and colored and pink and then
you put the original text on top again
you can take this a little bit further
and create something like this you can
create outline only text so for example
if you have this outline here and you
can put it on any kind of background
anything that happens in the background
will be reflected inside of the text and
this is also possible using the exact
same technique or changing it a little
bit and then adding one filter to it so
we're gonna start with morphology again
we're gonna make the text thicker but
what i'm doing here is into instead of
taking the source alpha which which is
black and then i'm gonna have to color
it with Fe flood and f8 composite which
is a little bit too much I'm taking the
source graphic itself which is my text
right the text is going to be originally
black or any other fill color that you
want and then you're making the text
thicker okay and then you're using the
composite with the operator out so you
have the thicker text and the background
and then you take the original text you
put it on top and you cut it out so
you're creating sort of a hole in the
thicker text from by using the original
text and the most important part here is
because I'm not using Fe flood to color
the outline the outline has the same
color as the source graphic so the same
color as the text which gets its color
using the fill attribute which ki can't
specify using CSS so if you use this
flow through here just these two steps
you can create outline text and then you
can style that text and change the color
and CSS which is perfect for separation
of concerns the next thing here what
this is the thing that I'm most excited
about the demo I showed this demo to a
lot of people and some of them said well
I thought this was created using 3d max
and another one was like oh my god this
is SVG I said yes so in this section I'm
gonna talk about how you can use an
image of a texture any texture and then
use it to change the shape or apply a
texture and change the shape of text
okay in particular I want to create this
effect that I borrowed from a Photoshop
tutorial that I found on YouTube because
I'm not a designer I have no idea how to
have to do things in Photoshop so
what I do want to come when I want to
experiment with SVG filters as I find a
really nice Photoshop tutorial I follow
the steps that they make and then I
recreate those steps with filters now in
the video the designer created this
effect by using what is known as a
displacement map a displacement map is
an image whose color information is used
to distort the content of another
element they have an image it has colors
those colors will be used to distort
another element that is put on top of it
an SVG filters the FE displacement map
primitive uses the pixels values from
the input image that you give it to
spatially displace the image from
another input so displacement map takes
two inputs one of them is the texture or
the map and the other one is the element
that you want to apply the texture to
the steps to recreate that are in
Photoshop you want to desaturate the
image turn it into black and white
according to the designer then you want
to reduce the amount of detail in it by
blurring it by just one pixel because
the more detail you have on an image the
less realistic that effect is going to
be so you blur it by one pixel which is
just enough if you blur it more it's
gonna be too little detail and it's also
B it will also be very unrealistic you
save that image the black and white
slightly blurred you save it as a
displacement map and then you reuse that
image you open it again but use it as a
displacement map to distort some text
okay so the text now has changed but you
don't see a background image so you take
the original image again you use it as a
background and then you composite the
text with the background to make the
effect even more realistic in SVG fill
the region area with the image that will
be used as a texture so we have an image
we're going to fill the region region
area with that image we're going to
desaturate it using color matrix which
is another filter primitive with a value
saturate just like saturating CSS if you
set the saturate to zero the image is
going to be d saturated you apply a 1
pixel Gaussian blur to the image using a
few Gaussian blur use the image to
distort the text with displacement map
blend the text into the background image
using blend and apply a translucent
effect to it just to make it a little
bit more realistic by decreasing the
opacity using component transfer and
then we display the text on the image
behind it by more
the two layers again this is the coat so
we're gonna start with Effie image and
then she literally just gets an image
and puts it in the region area it's
gonna fill the region area with it it
even comes with a preserve aspect ratio
so if you want to preserve the aspect
ratio of the image or if you want to
just fill the area in regardless of the
aspect ratio you can do that and then
you desaturate the image with color
matrix color matrix tape it takes many
types one of them which is saturate
which is just a shorthand for a specific
color matrix it's just for convenience
and it's available for us so if you use
type saturate values zero you're going
to desaturate the image and then you
decrease the level of details by
applying a Gaussian blur on the image
itself in this case I've used the 0.5
because I found that to be more even
more realistic than 1 pixels and that
result is a map and this is what it
looks like okay then you use that map as
a displacement map to displace the text
which is our source graphic so the
displace in the map takes and a source
graphic and then it takes the n2 it's
called you can only have N and in to
know and three you know and four and the
end two is the map so the map here is
going to be used to displace the text
and the scale is 15 the scale allows you
to specify the amount or the scale by
which you want the effect to be applied
the larger the scale the more the more
dramatic the effect is going to be the
channel selector is only you're
essentially telling the browser which
colors you want to use to apply the
distortion and then there is a result
which is texture check a texture text
and then using the color matrix on that
texture text you can reduce the opacity
so a color matrix has the matrix for RGB
a plus an offset at the end that's why
you have five columns and then four rows
for RGB a so the zero point nine there
that's where the opacity is it's
initially one in the identity matrix and
I just turned it into zero point zero
point nine this is what the text now
looks like it has been changed displaced
using the texture now I want to show the
texture no first I want to decrease the
opacity okay I didn't decrease the
opacity I add now the image again back
in the background
using EFI image again and then you can
change the gamma what I'm doing it is
just a little bit of tweaking just like
the Photoshop guy did I'm adding
increasing the contrast of the image
using component transfer the component
transfer is very similar to matrix but
instead of using a matrix you can you
can have a channel for each one of those
components RGB and even a and then you
can use functions to change the values
in those channels now the type gamma the
component transfer type gamma literally
works on the gamma of an image so it it
manipulates and changes the lightness
and the dark areas of the image so if
you make the dark areas darker you're
increasing the contrast and if you make
the the light areas lighter with the
darker dark areas you're increasing the
contrast and this is what I'm doing here
changing the amplitude and exponent as
much as going to make the dark areas
darker and make the light areas lighter
so we have this displace text in the
background re added the original image
and tweak the contrast a little bit of
that image and this is the background
now and then you blend the text with a
background using the blend primitive so
again the blend takes two inputs noir
that you want to blend to add together
the mode can be multiply screen one of
the many blend options that you have in
CSS except that you only have like four
or five in SVG
but you can definitely recreate the
others on your own so I'm multiplying
the text with the background and then
I'm merging the two on top of each other
to get this result now the color could
be made even more realistic I just
didn't have a little I just didn't have
the time to do it if instead of using
multiplier you use a linear burn I would
have to recreate the linear burn effect
and then apply it then it becomes even
more realistic similar to this here this
is the original tutorial and this is how
you displace text with SVG filters thank
you
now in addition to getting an external
texture and applying its own element SPG
is even more cooler it allows you to
create your own texture that you can use
as a displacement map later
so filters can generate too rich
textures you can create fire textures
cloud textures marble stone paper and
we're going to create paper shortly we
can do that using the turbulence
function the turbulence filter whenever
I say function I mean filter the
turbulence filter primitive generates
and renders Perlin noise this kind of
noise is useful in simulating several
natural phenomena like clouds fire smoke
and in generating complex texture like
marble marble organ night just like
Effie flood when use F if F E flat you
flood the entire region with a color if
you use turbulence you flood the entire
region with a noise that we're gonna see
shortly now in this session I'm gonna go
over how you can create noise with Fe
turbulence and how that noise can first
be used to distort images and text
distort images and text and then we're
going to see how the noise can be
generated with this primitive and
combination with SVG lighting filters so
you have a texture and then you apply
some light to it and you turn that into
real you have noise and you apply light
to it you turn it into a texture and the
more different the noise the more
different the end result is going to be
so this is what Fe turbulence looks like
here you will usually only have to worry
about three attributes the base
frequency it specifies the grain of the
noise very low values such as 0.001 will
produce larger patterns you see on an
example shortly and very high values
such as 0.5 will produce tiny patterns
values in the range of 0.02 and 0.2 are
a useful starting point for most
textures there are also two types of
noise fractal noise and turbulence the
fractal noise is the more smooth one
it's it gets you closer to clouds and
those kinds of effects and then there is
the num of tabs which is the number of
octaves which very similar to music is
just the number of levels
the higher the number of octaves the
higher the number of layers you have and
therefore
the higher the detail level so these are
these twelve images represent twelve
different results of noise created with
turbulence with different types based
frequency and Nam octave values just to
quickly go over them an image you have a
base frequency of 0.04 this is a
standard noise we're not playing with
any of the other values just a base
frequency of 0.04 B is the same as a but
to increase the level of details with
number of tabs to so if you look at it
as B is exactly the same as is the
contrast good enough can you see them
okay so B is the same as a but with a
little bit more detail if you look
inside of it C is the same as B but we
change the seat to 201
so essentially what the seat does it
affects the shape drastically just not
in a way that's understandable it's just
that to generate the turbulence you need
to generate a bunch of random numbers
that's random noise and if you want the
same randomness the same randomness in
multiple faces for example over multiple
elements that are next to each other you
can start the generator from the same
seed multiple times so the seed is sort
of like changes it's a random number
that the browser's going to use to start
the randomness from D is the same as C
with the number of times five so we've
increased the level in d e shows that
noise is continuous so if you have a and
E let's start with the same with the
same seed and you put them next to each
other you're gonna see that the noise is
continuous from A to E it's like it's
the same noise da F is decreasing the
base frequency to 0.01 and that will
create larger patterns so if you look at
F this is a larger pattern and then you
have the smaller patterns each one of
these can be used to create different
textures GNH show the difference in the
number of octaves again between G and H
I and J is nice but that is using
fractal noise not turbulence so if you
look at all the ones like AE b c d @ GH
all of these are like intricate noise
and then i and j are more cloudy and
more vague and more blurred these can be
used to create clouds for example okay
and I'll show you that you can change
the size of the noise the size of the
turbulence along the x-axis and
y-axis so if you look at L for example
you can create that effect and you can
some create some really nice effect with
that an example that I have now is this
is a demo online that shows you how we
can apply an effect so if you choose
turbulence and you use the turbulence as
a displacement map on this image this is
what it looks like and then you can
change the scale to make it more
dramatic or less dramatic and then we
can also apply the same texture to text
which will give you that warping text
effect dirk Weber used FK turbulence as
a displacement map on text to create
this water splash effect which is
available in Smashing Magazine and then
code drops they have this really nice
button effects that are also using noise
and your animating that noise because
all the numbers all of the values and
the noise are animatable so if you
animate those you can end up with these
effects I like this one the most is that
the music one this is a vertical noise
like the one you show earlier and but
you're just animating it now what I want
to talk about now is how you can this
lose this noise this turbulence plus
lighting effects to create texture and
more specifically I want to create a
very simple rough paper texture which I
borrowed from Michael Milani by the way
online
this texture requires literally two
steps two functions two primitives and
then you can do anything with it you can
use it as a displacement map or whatever
you want to do so first we're gonna
start by creating the base for this
whole effect with the turbulence
primitive we're not specifying a type on
the turbulence at at this point so we're
getting toward turbulence not that
cloudy effect
yeah we're creating the base frequency
0.04 which is a fairly good start most
of the times I just experiment so I just
change the values to see which one gets
me closer to my to my goal and then I
have a rectangle that I'm applying this
texture to this is what I have this is
what you start with now we need to shine
a light on that surface shining a light
on graphic provides additional depth and
texture and to create a lighting effect
you need to specify three things a light
color specified by the lighting color
proper lighting color property you're
going to see shortly and
type which is specified using a light
source which no a light type so you can
there is diffused lighting and there is
specular lighting and SVG the diffused
lighting indicates indirect light from
an outside source and is best used for
some light effects something to simulate
Sun you use diffuse lighting if you want
something to simulate more of a lamp or
a room and a light inside of a room you
use specular lighting which specifies
secondary light that bounced from
reflective surfaces both these primitive
shine light on an object or image by
using the Alpha channel of that image as
a bump map transparent values remain
flat while elpac values rise to form
Peaks so if you have let me rephrase
that
a light source filter uses an input
alpha channel to provide depth
information you have an alpha Channel
you take the Alpha values of that
channel and then you use those as a bump
map for the light so how do how does the
light know that this part of it is high
and the other one is low how do you
create shadows and Hills it uses the
Alpha Channel to do that the more
transparent the lower and flatter it is
the more opac the higher it is because
Fe turbulence generates an alpha channel
full of noisy values so red green blue
are noisy and random so is alpha it
comes with a lot of different alpha
values it produces a nice variable Z
terrain that creates highlights when we
shine our light on it I know there are
two yeah so there are two types of light
and there are two sources of light to
create a light source you nest the light
source inside of the light type so you
have type source inside of it and then
you finally specify the lighting color
so to light the noise we generated
earlier we will apply a white diffused
lighting which is sunlight emanating
from a distant light source and this is
what the code looks like both of these
primitives accept an attribute called
surface scale which is the set index
multiplier so if you increase the scale
does that index is going to be higher
and you can gotta get more steeper
steeper visual slopes and your texture
then you have azimuth and azimuth and
elevation on the light source as you can
see in this graphic here from the
specification as the most azimuth and
elevation both of them specify where the
light source is coming from essential
and you also need to play with that
because the closer you make it to the
texture the different the effect and the
lighting is going to be so we have here
turbulence and then we have a lighting
apply to that turbulence this is what we
get there is too much sharp edges here
so we need to smooth the noise out we
can do that by using fractal noise to
start with instead of using turbulence
switching the type to fractal fractal
fractal noise gives us a better base
which is this it is smoother a little
bit more like water in this case it's
not really rough paper rock paper has
more detail so we need to increase the
detail and we can do that by increasing
the number of log tabs
five octaves is usually the highest you
will need for most of your effects if
you have six and more the effect is not
very visible if you have a very sharp
eye you can't you can notice a little
bit of difference I do
but most of the times it's not really
that big of a difference so if we
increase the number of octaves it gets a
little bit more grain and it looks much
better than generally you can change the
effect a little bit and tweak it more by
playing with the source and the distance
distance of the light maybe even the
color if you change the color this is
going to be colored rough paper
decreasing the elevation on the light
source for example it's going to make it
look like this it's a little bit of
darker which brings us a little bit more
to sandpaper which is not what we want
we want to rough paper so I think the
previous version looked just fine and
that's all you need to create a simple
texture you need noise and you apply
some text to it and then you can use
this texture to use it as a displacement
map so if you want to simulate writing
on paper you can do that you can do
pretty much anything with this now we
before you can also create a myriad
myriad of different effects if you take
that noise and you apply different other
filters to it so this is an example here
this is each
violence some of them may might look
like more closer to bouquet effect
others like like fireworks are something
what we're doing here and the ones on
top we're blurring we're changing the
colors using color matrix and then on
the one at the ones in the ones at the
bottom we're changing the sharpness by
using con twelve major convolve matrix
that's filtered for motive I'm not going
to talk about that because that won't
occur
it requires an entire hour and it's the
most complex of all filters because it
allows you to create your own filters
and filter to create filters so you can
do a lot of things if you have noise if
you delete colors you're going to end up
with a different texture you can do
anything
essentially the sky's the limit now
before we end this talk I want to give a
short overview of two primitives that
are also the most used that enable you
to manipulate the colors of images so we
talked about thinning and thickening of
text or of images we talked about
blending compositing turbulence textures
displacement maps there's a lot more but
I want to cover image color manipulation
just like the ones you can find in CSS
so more specifically I want to cover
poster effects something that would
create a poster version of whatever you
have
unlike Chris island I do draw a little
bit so the one the image on the Left I
drew that using pastels and then I
turned that digitally into a poster
version so you have the real pastel with
all of the color gradients and then on
the right side you turn that into a
poster effect now this effect can be
created using discrete component
transfer function okay I'm gonna go over
that shortly but what what when you use
this function here it's called component
transfer again RGB a lot of control you
can use different functions we use the
gamma function earlier to control
contrast and brightness and then you
have the discrete function the discrete
function has four different attribute
which is called table values it reduces
the number of colors in an image and
shows more sudden color changes which
look more like the images made up of
color bands or color clusters so again
if you look at this instead of having a
gradient of every single color every
color you
les couleurs the browser deuce this does
this by doing some sort of mapping so if
you have for example table values set to
zero zero point five one you can have as
many values as you want the more values
you give the more ranges you have and
the browser is going to map the color to
these ranges so if you have a red color
for example between the range zero and
0.33 the browser is going to map it to
just zero so all of the shades between
zero and zero point three will just be
one shade less color zero point three is
0.66 will be mapped to your zero point
five so you only have three shades of
red you're decreasing the number of
colors and they're forgetting that
poster effect and this is what you get
here so all I did is I gave I use
discrete I used three different colors
and then the browser is going to take
the whole shades of red and green and
blue and it's going to map the shades
into the ranges I specify here another
thing is I want to create a dual tone
effect with contrast control so to
create the dual tone effect in Photoshop
usually do two steps you turn the image
into grayscale and then you map the
greyscale range into a new range that
instead of having black and white on the
edges so instead of a range from black
to white you map that to arrange from
pink to yellow or whatever color you
want to do in other words you will need
a gradient map that the browser will use
to map your greyscale image to now this
is the tutorial that I found on YouTube
again so you have this black and white
and then you're gonna do a little bit of
mapping you change the black to some
color that you want so all of the shades
of black will be transferred to this or
map to this color and then the white you
change that into your other color and
you get written effect like the one from
Spotify how do you do that in SVG you
need to create a gradient map using
component transfer but instead of using
the discrete value which limits the
number of colors were going to use the
table value in order to map your colors
into a new range of colors without
losing any colors
like we do indiscreet you can use the
component transfer type table so suppose
you want to create the duotone image
using these two colors here you have a
pink color and then you have another
color for every one of those colors the
two colors you get the RGB values which
you have on the right and then you
divide that value the R value the G
value and the B value divide that you
divide that by 255 you get a small
decimal value and that's what you're
going to use and the function here so
these three here are G B are the RGB of
pink and the other ones here RGB are the
values for the other color so red is
going to be mapped from black and white
to these to rate this range and then G
is going to be mapped to this range and
B to this and that gives you the dual
tone effect this looks nice but it does
look like it's missing something if you
increase the lightness of the colors
increase the lightness of the yellow and
increase the intensity of the pink the
color of the the effect becomes a little
bit more realistic so you can do that
again by using the gamma function of
component transfer increasing the
amplitude decreasing the the exponent a
little bit of tweaking you get a better
result now you may have noticed an
attribute on the component transfer
filter here is called color
interpolation filters this attribute is
used to switch from and between the
linear RGB space and the srgb space it
is useful to get more desert deserve
desirable results when applying certain
effects for example if you want to apply
a an inversion effect if you will have
an image and you want to invert the
colors of that image if you use the
default linear RGB space you're going to
end up with the result on the right
which is not very desirable the one you
want is the one on the left with more
intense colors now the reason this
happens this is not really wrong the
mapping is happening it's correct
everything is working as expected but
because of the way the human eye
perceives colors lighter tones always
look more like actual just white to us
so we have all the tones we need and the
right one but it's
our eyes are seeing it in a two light
way in order to change this and get more
darker shades and less lighter shades
you can switch to the srgb space and you
get a more desirable not more rights
because both of them are correct you get
a more desirable effect yeah before
before the thank you just a quick note
so if you use any kind of coloring
effects in SVG and you get the colors
are not really just like you expected
the image is too light most of the times
the solution is going to be to switch
the color interpret interpolation
filters to srgb
and that is all I have thank you so much
thank you sir
thanks a lot